die bundesfamilienministerin eine
spiegel ist am montag zurückgetreten
nach langer hitziger diskussion in
diesem land wir haben alle erfahren von
den chat verläufen in denen deutlich
wurde dass es ihr mehr um ihr
öffentliches ansehen als um das helfen
der dortigen opfer geht wir haben
erfahren dass sie vier wochen im urlaub
war und davon nichts gesagt hat sie hat
auch die unwahrheit gesagt dass sie
angeblich an kabinettssitzungen in
dieser zeit teilgenommen das hat sie
nicht getan in diesem zusammenhang
entstand die debatte darüber ob
politiker politikerinnen in
spitzenfunktionen familie und beruf
tatsächlich vereinbaren können wir haben
erfahren dass frau spiegel in einer sehr
schwierigen familiären situation sich
leider befindet vier kindern mit einem
ehemann der auch 2009 10 einen
schlaganfall hatte alles nicht sehr
leicht wir können das alle
nachvollziehen aber die frage steht im
raum ist jetzt das system politik daran
schuld dass frau spiegel lügen musste
dass frau spiegel sich in einer
bundesweiten notsituation in den urlaub
gegeben hat ich sage nein das system ist
nicht schuld jemand der zwei ministerien
leitet und sich dazu bereit erklärt
jemand der in dieser zeit die
spitzenkandidatur im landtagswahlkampf
übernimmt und dann noch in den bund
wechselt um dort bundesministerin zu
werden der hat sich viele viele fragen
zu stellen gehabt und sich für die
politik entschieden und wir müssen
endlich mal ehrlich sein und den leuten
auch sagen gerade auf den jungen frauen
in diesem land sagen dass man im leben
wirklich nicht alles haben kann man muss
sich manchmal entscheiden möchte ich
mehr rücksicht auf meine familie nehmen
oder ist mir mein beruf wichtiger und
wenn ich mich entscheide in die politik
zu gehen und dort ein spitzenamt ausüben
oder sogar mehrere dann brauche ich
natürlich zu hause jemanden der mir
rückhalt gibt ja der mir hilft er sich
um die kinder kümmert ich finde da ist
ein bisschen mehr ehrlichkeit angebracht
dass diese debatte auch so zu führen
nicht immer so zu tun als wenn im leben
alles möglich ist als wenn wir fünf
kinder haben können work-life-balance
haben einen tollen mann und auch noch
nie karriere ich glaube das ist märchen
und das wird nicht funktionieren
was schimpfe ich glaube wir sind uns in
einem punkt er komplett einig dass weder
das system schuld ist und dazu kommt
auch das ist ganz bestimmt nicht ihre
familiäre situation schon zu hause
gewesen sondern schlicht und ergreifend
ihr katastrophales krisenmanagement
damit einhergehend auch die art und
weise der kommunikation ich glaube diese
legendäre pressekonferenz ist uns noch
allen gut in erinnerung zumindestens der
sie gesehen hat wird sich so schnell
nicht vergessen
dazu kommt das ja auch erst nach
deutlich um druck aus den eigenen reihen
von den kabinettskollegen von der
parteispitze erst mal aufgewacht ist und
gesagt hat so wir ziehen sie jetzt mal
aus der schusslinie heraus dass gibt
keinen mehr dann was ich sag mal ich
komme ja auch aus einem entsprechenden
haushalte haben einen fernseher war 23
jahre langen deutschen wm-fans wolfgang
bosbach cdu politiker ich denke immer
kanzler der herzen übrigens wenn er da
ist er das heißt ich kann zu dieser
debatte tatsächlich irgendetwas beitrag
nicht nur weil ich selber im politischen
milieu tätig bin und auch diverse
ehrenämter habe die mich oftmals bis in
die späten armen und vor allem auch
nachts stunden beschäftigen ist ein
schwieriges thema aber
es ist kein nein to five job und in
diesem fall muss zu wissen das land
steht vor der person das ist doch völlig
klar wenn du dich um ein solches amt
auch bewirbst und das ist auch wichtig
nach außen zu kommunizieren hat kannst
du die schuld nicht abnehmen kannste
wlan system in die schuhe schieben noch
der familie da ist doch dass das dass
das grund des absolute basis wissen aber
jetzt mal so rein von dieser
ministeriale weg aus eigener erfahrung
dass ist auch ein stück weit weiß ich
gerne ganzen würde was wir zur debatte
einfach hinzufügen müssen grad bei uns
in der union wir haben wenig wir haben
junge frauen die sehr weit nach oben
wollen die auch richtig kämpfen wir sind
tatsächlich weniger bekannt die es
schaffen die ganzen kinder zu bekommen
diese möchten und trotzdem einfach vorne
zu kommen woran liegt das ich habe mir
sagen ich bin schon der meinung dass die
ein oder andere strukturelle reformen
oder andere entgegenkommen nötig wäre
ich rede hier nicht von umwälzungen oder
von absolut reformen und struktur
umwälzenden prozessen es ist so und das
werden auch die anderen kollegen
bestätigen auch parteiübergreifend
sitzungen bis in die abendstunden sind
lagen sie sind vermögend es muss alles
im präsens stattfinden das kann nicht
digital stattfinden und es ist auch in
jeder partei so wenn du nicht über 7
oder zwölf jahre hinweg jeden dienstag
zum stammtisch kommt und da wirklich
durchhält und aus als das sind auch
keine entschuldigungen zugelassen so
wird das nicht es ist verdammt schwierig
ich habe für mich schon persönlich den
anspruch dass ich das alles unter einen
hut bekommen möchte kann aber auch
sowohl von meinem vater also wirklich
aus allererster ebene was ich zu hause
erlebt habe all die jahre und auch von
dem was ich jetzt gerade erlebe da ein
ganz großes
thema könnte man da los treten aber ich
diskutieren was benötigen würde um auch
gerade für junge frauen diese ganze
szenen diesen ganzen dorf attraktiver zu
machen wenn ich muss darüber reden platz
zwei ist ein total wichtiger punkt
hierbei das thema vereinbarkeit von
familie und beruf nicht nur
politiker betrifft sondern aus eigener
erfahrung kann ich sagen auch
journalisten aber da gibt es sicherlich
noch ganz ganz viele andere berufe die
genau das die gleiche herausforderung
mit sich bringen für männer und für
frauen ist ja nicht nur so dass frauen
mütter sind sondern männer können ja
auch väter sein und darüber wird in der
politik ja auch sehr sehr selten
gesprochen ich glaube wir sehen aber
auch und sie haben das ja auch gerade
gesagt bei frau spiegel war
möglicherweise dieses amt des
bundesministers oder der
bundesministerin einfachen amt was
vielleicht auch einfach einen ticken zu
groß war es gibt ja immer die füllt man
einfach aus weil man auch dafür brennt
und warte bei frau spiegel ich nicht den
eindruck dass das so richtig der fall
war und was ich eigentlich eigentlich
muss ich sagen bedauerlich fand an dem
ganzen auftritt sie hat ja ein
persönliches schicksal das tragisch ist
schicksal gegenübergestellt die
mindestens genauso tragisch sind oder
waren der flutkatastrophe diejenigen
nämlich die angehörige oder freunde
verloren haben und auch noch ihr hab und
gut da muss man sagen geht es ja frau
spiegel fast noch gut dagegen ohne dass
ich das irgendwie jetzt schönreden will
aber die situation war sicherlich in
ihrer familie eine andere als sie viele
viele familien im flutgebiet erlebt
haben und auch glaube ich da hat sie
einfach absolut die falschen worte
gefunden an dem abend nur wenn wir einig
dass rechner kurz einwerfen darf wenn
wir frauen wirklich helfen wollen wenn
wir frauen in die lage versetzen wollen
um karriere zu machen eine
führungsaufgaben zu übernehmen dann
müssen wir auch über die konsequenzen
reden die das mit sich bringt das ist
eben nicht nur ein teich und das ist
auch kein spaziergang das ist auch
ellbogen ja und das ist auch austeilen
können und das finde ich findet in der
deutschen debatte überhaupt nicht statt
wir von seiten der politik also gerieren
immer das ist alles gar kein problem wir
brauchen nur eine frauenquote und schon
ist das problem gelöst die aber das ist
ja nicht der fall das ist ja nicht der
fall frauen die war da was vorhaben
brauchen so viel unterstützung offen so
viele ratschläge brauchen mentoren
brauchen menschen die ihnen auch mal ein
bisschen sagen dass soja und das findet
nicht statt und es irgendwann ist es
eine sehr unehrliche debatte die wir
brauchen das nicht auch männer also ich
habe mittlerweile auch bei ich meine die
männer wollen ja vielleicht auch zu
hause bleiben wir sprechen über
frauenquoten und besonders auch über
mentoren für frauen aber ist es nicht
auch so dass vielleicht für alle schön
wäre wenn sich das etwas ändert im
politbetrieb naja so meine beobachtung
ist die dass männer einfach mal anders
sind frauen und männer sind
unterschiedlich und die ticken anders
und die vernetzten sich anders und die
männer vernetzen sich sehr sehr früh wir
haben in deutschland sehr lebendige
strukturen mit netzwerken mit bünden ja
die schon in studentenzeiten gegründet
werden und da unterstützt man sich eben
zum beispiel auch ein leben lang und die
ticken auch die spielen zusammen fußball
die machen so gemeinsame dinge die ihnen
spaß machen ja ich weiß nicht ob wir
frauen das so machen ich glaube weniger
ja und das ist ein kernproblem oder das
jetzt aber glaubt der debatte die total
wichtig ist die ist so direkt
angeschlossen an den rücktritt von einem
spiegel mutter mit vier kindern dass es
das ist ein großer job den sie allein zu
hause hat mit ihrem mann zusammen und
dann noch einen job aber ich glaube
lasst uns das doch einmal reduzieren auf
das auf das faktum und da muss man
einfach sagen das hat man auch in der
pressekonferenz gesehen dieser job war
für eine spiegel ob sie kinder hätte
gehabt hat oder nicht ob sie verheiratet
ist oder wie auch immer der job war zu
groß ja und jetzt wird gleich eine
familien debatte draus gemacht also das
finde ich ein bisschen unehrlich lasst
uns doch festhalten es gibt jobs für die
sind einige menschen total geeignet und
für andere sind sie nicht geeignet und
wir müssen aber feststellen für anne
spiegel bei dieser job einfach zu groß
er bei mir neben dem kopf geschüttelt
werden sie unsere debatte zugehört habe
ich mir gedacht habe es gar nicht sein
dass wir in deutschland im jahr 2022
gebe noch auf dem niveau sind männer und
frauen sind heute unterschiedlichen
schulen es kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein
oder also das erwarte ich mir überhaupt
nicht und das was sie gerade ansprechen
ist vollkommen richtig ich glaube wir
haben hier zwei verschiedene ebenen von
einem ganz wichtigen thema das eine
thema zu dem ich mich äußern möchte weil
ich die hintergründe nicht genug eine
ist ist die frau spiegelglatten gewesen
aber nicht irrelevant viel wichtiger ist
eigentlich die frage unter die familien
debatte die sie
so bezeichnen weil das ist wirklich ein
grundsatzthemen ich glaube da steckt
schon auch da drinnen und das kann man
nicht reduzieren auf männer und frauen
sind halt unterschiedliche männer tun
halt besser netzwerken als frauen usw
sondern ein strukturproblem und
strukturproblem heißt letztlich ein
gesellschaftliches ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem ich bin
selber vater eines fünfjährigen sohnes
und ich weiß ganz genau meine frau ist
selber auch sehr stark aktives auch die
fortsetzung unserer stiftung hat ganz
andere herausforderungen und muss sich
bei jeder einzelnen diskussion mit der
frage konfrontieren lassen muss man
eigentlich dem kind und ich sehe dass
auch frauen werde anders behandelt ich
habe sie ich habe schon vorher erzählt
ich habe sie googelt das erstmals kommt
ist mit dem sie liiert waren irgendwann
also es sind frauen in der politik das
soll ich werde nicht zu nahe treten aber
ich meine google ist und du siehst
allein schon bei algorithmus seit das
zeigt ja etwas und das ist ja nicht
etwas natur gemacht er ist also nicht so
dass unseren biologie uns darauf tritt
sondern sie ist eine gewisse und
gesellschaftliche trichter hermann laue
jemand sich nur einmal die den flügel
rasen und zwar bei bei mir wird auch bei
google steht immer man oder verheiratet
kinder oder so sind auch bei mir die
ersten google anfang das ist aber auch
bei männern so weil auch wenn ich
manchmal jemand google steht ja auch
frauen verheiratet ich glaube das hat
auch was emotionen des menschen vor
allem daran interessiert und was noch
nicht wagen macht also
das ist ja auch dass ich auch eine gute
sache habe ich glaube wir reden von
politik und politik heißt dort wird das
volk abgebildet das heißt unsere
repräsentanten in österreichs 183
abgeordneten die entscheiden was
übrigens gesetz gewährt ist und was
nicht das entscheidet auch darüber was
unserem land gemacht wird man das nicht
und ich glaube dass die politik bis zum
gewissen grade auch ein spiegelbild
unserer gesellschaft sein muss und wenn
wir jetzt erleben wie sie sagen das ist
in wirklichkeit keine kompatibilität von
einem menschenwürdigen leben und einer
politischen karriere das wird so
geschwitzt habe ich das nicht gesagt und
ich spreche jetzt komplett frage ist
aber nicht gesagt ich möchte im übrigen
auch verstimmte absolut beipflichten
wenn sie das anders sehen ich betone das
jetzt noch mal es gibt diese
unterschiede und es gibt diese
schwierigkeiten punkt also hatte ich
jedesmal und trommeln sind ja und vor
allem wenn man dafür wenn man hier im
politischen kontext uns bewegen und
davon
es gibt selbstverständlich die ja
natürlich habe die arbeit aber in
schuldig sie die unterschiede auf
politischer ebene sind doch wohl
hoffentlich nicht biologistisch erzeugt
er da hoffen sie leider fehlt also das
ist tatsächlich schon so ich kann das
bestätigen es ist frauen arbeiten anders
frauen sind in der politik in einem
absoluten ellbogen geschäft das ich
erlebt er jeden tag wer setzt angela
merkel gesehen wird das wasser wieder
angela merkel gesehen wie gut sie eine
frau an der spitze des staates eine frau
ja die hat nicht über eine frau wir
reden gerade über frauen in der breite
in der gesellschaft und in der politik
das hat nichts mit angela merkel zu tun
ja sie gehört dazu sie gehört dazu aber
sie ist bei weitem nicht als
paradebeispiel wo wir zu identifizieren
würden und sagen der allergrößte teil
der frauen kann sich jetzt damit würde
jetzt sagen dass sie mit den
gemeinsamkeiten hat und sich damit
irgendwie ja identifiziert oder sehen
sie dann vor ich meine kinder bekommen
habe habe ich immer geglaubt okay wenn
du dem kind eine rosa eine bohrmaschine
kaufst dann buttermann maschinen nicht
nur maschinen bauerin daraus ja aber wie
ist die realität man sieht schon bei
zweijährigen bei dreijährigen dass die
interessen komplett und achsen und da tu
ich gar nichts weil er vollkommen recht
so und daraufhin aus und das ist eben
die die interessen sind von beginn an
sehr sehr unterschieden klar und auch im
sozialen verhalten sehr unterschiedlich
jungs machen so mädchen machen so kommt
ein junges mädchen aber hier geht es um
politik und schulpolitik ist nicht
baugewerbe oder stricken
politik heißt treten wenn nicht dann
haben wir ein problem im politischen
system und ich glaube dass dieses thema
politik muss heißen dass die
repräsentantinnen und repräsentanten der
bürgerinnen und bürger drinnen sitzung
nicht nur die nachrichtlichen
politikerinnen und polizist abzu
gesichtslosen ist heilig sein sollte
waren japan status quo ich dachte wir
reden darüber wie es sein sollte
unschuldige ich muss mich anpassen ich
habe das zusammenbringt einmal zu sagen
was gerade ist und einmal das ideal war
ich viel zu sagen wie es sein soll wir
sehen aber auch und das ist dann auch
wieder bemerkenswert die grünen haben
sich ja sehr schnell festgelegt bei der
frage wer wird eigentlich als nachfolger
von anne spiegel soll eine frau werden
und sie soll aus dem linken lager kommen
und wir warten seit 48 stunden oder
weniger gebannt also das land kann auch
glaube ich ohne familienministerin
auskommen wie wir sehen aber wir warten
trotzdem jahr 38 stunden gewann es gibt
zu werden wer glaubt denn nun und
offenbar ist das auch mal wieder gar
nicht so einfach hat man also sich schon
wieder zu stark festgelegt auch eine
frage der energie beide also muss es
jetzt frauen links sein oder
besser golf wo wir sehen wohin
quotierungen führen ja haben eine kurze
unterbrechung gehen dennoch an sachen
frage frauchen geweckt könntest denn
jetzt werden ob sie vielleicht noch ein
tipp für den zuschauer wer vielleicht
nächster familien minister für
ministerin wird oder wer es sein sollte
wer gut wird ich habe keine ahnung wenn
ich ehrlich bin also ich bin da auch
nicht zu nahe dran ich bin auch nicht so
wirklich nah dran bei den grünen wie die
da ihre entscheidungen treffen ein paar
frauen gibt es ja tatsächlich noch in
der fraktion paar männer gibt es auch
man könnte in der tat die qualität des
amtes vielleicht auch eben wenn man wenn
man einfach sich da nicht so einschränkt
ja aber das sollen sie entscheiden keine
ahnung weiß ich nicht sehr gut das war
ein gutes schlusswort zu der these ob
mann oder frau hauptsache kompetent für
das hand des familienminister